[تصفيق]
نعم عماره مبروك علينا جميعا ومن لم يكن
يعتق
دم بعزيمه هؤلاء الرجال هؤلاء الابطال
الذين اثبتوا اليوم بان المغربيه والعربيه
ليس مستحيلا نعم نحن اليوم لدينا منتخب
عربي بين الاربعه الكبار علينا ان نحتفل
ونذكر بهذا الانجاز انجاز كبير يا عمار
يعني بعد سلسله من الاخفاقات الكرويه
اليوم انا لنا ان نحتفل انا لنا ان نفتخر
بهذا المنتخب في الوليدات الرجراجي
دينا رفعوا اسم العرب عاليا اطاحوا
باسبانيا واضاح اليوم
الاكيد الك
ل ورد ز
ميل لا ما زال تحت
اهو لكن هي صدمه جميله صدمه جميله من
النوع الذي يخترق القلب من النوع
يرسم البهجه في وجه
هؤلاء كان له دور كبير في هذا الانجاز منذ
اول مباراه
كرواتيا كلهم رغم كل الظروف اللي القاسي
الا انهم ابوا الا ان يكونوا حاضرين
ليشجعوا المنتخب المغربي بعضهم من استلف
بعضهم من اتى في ظروف قاسيه جدا لكن كل
هذا يهون كما يقولون كيف اليوم انجاز كبير
انجاز كبير خلاص فلسطيني انجاز رائع انجاز
تاريخي انجاز سفر اتذكره ونذكر اولاده
وابنائه واحفادنا المغرب فخر العرب الف
الف مبروك للمغرب العرب على فلسطيني من
الداخل ولكن اتيت هنا تشجع المغرب مبروك
المغرب والكاس ان شاء الله باذن الله
المغرب
اليوم مباراه المغرب والكل مبروك
ولد عربي